people will often ask me why I'm so
blunt why I'm so direct in my approach
and oftentimes they'll they'll phrase it
in a way that's a little bit less
flattering than that but that's
basically the the question you know you
will attract more flies with honey Matt
so people always tell me
and yeah I don't use a lot of honey I
admit that but first of all I'm not
interested in attracting flies why would
I want to attract flies
I've never understood that an expression
for the sake of the expression why would
you use the one thing that nobody wants
to attract but second I don't think the
expression holds anyway because you know
it appears to me that one of the great
problems in American society and really
kind of the the the film the protective
coating the shell that covers everything
in our culture is indifference apathy
intellectual and moral laziness is the
issue so if you want to get through to
people if you want to reach them if you
really want to engage them you got to
break through that sometimes and that
means necessarily being a little bit
more blunt and if in the process they
end up feeling attacked and judged and
if you hurt their feelings a little bit
well that's okay in fact it could even
be good you got to make them feel
something first make them care even if
that's how they could just just you got
to get them there first where they
actually care and they're angry so if
people get angry I mean I can take that
that's fine but at least they feel
something
at least for a moment they actually care
because I think most people don't
care
about like anything
we're always told that
the real problem the biggest problem for
America today is that is that there's so
much division and there's so much
partisanship and there's bigotry and
people are so firm in their beliefs and
they they refuse to compromise or to see
from the other perspective hate they
they're they're so filled with hate
right so we have to fight hate we're the
fight hate speech and hate crimes and
hate in every other form there's just
there's so much hate everywhere
which which i think is is so clearly not
the case not the case at all
when I look around America I don't see
people who are so firm and resolute and
dedicated to their beliefs
and so just unfired passionate about
about life and about what they believe
and you know to to it to a dangerous
extent without see it's even see even
hate in fact I'm even told people even
worry that we're headed towards a civil
war we're gonna break out in war again
like we did in 1861
I think we flatter ourselves when we
start talking like that there there's
not I hate to tell you this but there's
not gonna be any Civil War it's not
gonna happen we are far too lazy for
that we don't care nearly enough about
things for a civil war now I know the
conditions are different in 2018 than
they were in 1861 but just consider what
these men during the real Civil War the
first civil war the only civil war so
far consider what they went through what
they endured okay
Abbie we're talking about especially in
the south we're talking about these
these barely even men a lot of them 16
17 18 years old in many cases
that didn't meet they didn't have shoes
they didn't have food
they were they were walking like through
the the Shannon de la Mountains without
shoes on marching 20 to 25 miles a day
eating salt pork and black coffee that
tastes like motor oil made from acorns
okay they were charging headlong into
cannon fire
they would stand just yards apart and
and and and blow each other to pieces
with their rifles um it it's not like
they really had an aesthetic so if a
limb had to be amputated well you could
take a swig of whiskey and it was going
to be cut off
so that's the kind of conviction that
these men had in the Civil War they they
really believed in something they really
believed in a cause you could disagree
with the cause we we could debate what
the cause actually was you know that's
not the point
point is they believed in something they
believed in a cause and on both sides
and they were and they were willing to
fight for it we don't have that kind of
conviction
most of us we don't have anywhere near
that kind of conviction I'll tell you
why a civil war wouldn't happen because
a civil war would almost certainly mean
that we're all gonna lose that there's
not gonna be a cable or Internet for a
while there's probably not gonna be
Netflix it's not gonna be time to watch
it
the moment we started losing our
luxuries we live in this country with
such insane indulgent luxury
at the moment we started to lose those
things we would say up never mind
never mind forget it like our
electricity goes off and we're out we're
without air-conditioning for two days
that would be enough all right and
forget the whole thing guys let's forget
this civil war thing what do you think
you know I thought we were fighting a
civil war I didn't know I didn't know
I'd have to sacrifice my video game time
I mean nobody told me that was part of
the bargain now I don't say this with
with disappointment by the way I don't
mean to come across like I'm
disappointed like I want a civil war of
course I don't
600,000 people died in the Civil War was
a horrible horrific thing I'm just
trying to make the point that hatred is
not the thing destroying our society
hatred could destroy society it's an
awful thing it's destroyed many
societies in the past division
partisanship all those things I can be
can literally split apart countries as
we witnessed ourself but our case is
different the cancer in our bloodstream
I really believe is indifference it is
apathy
um the problem is we've misdiagnosed all
the symptoms
for instance we see these occasional
bursts of violence and chaos in the
streets on the part of BLM or an tyfa or
that one time when it was white
nationalist and we see that and we say
okay well that's bigotry hatred see
we're on the verge of civil war
no you know what that really was and is
its nihilism there's people there just
looking for an excuse to throw rocks and
the burn cop cars and they found a
convenient excuse but that's really it's
just a destructive impulse remember
famously the mayor of Baltimore during
the rides in Baltimore she said well we
have to give them space to destroy right
it's a great leadership on her part
but but that's that's really what they
wanted it was really they just wanted a
space to destroy why they were
destroying things you know didn't really
matter in fact if you would asked if you
had pulled any one of them out and
interviewed them and some people did do
this that well what do you what are you
so upset about but in many cases they
couldn't even tell you what they're
upset about just not not because they're
not upset they just were looking for a
reason to do this and so they did that
was nihilism
the same can be said for many of the
recent mass shootings I make this point
every time there's a mass shooting
because I think it's it's so important
to realize that in most cases when you
hear about these these these monsters
who go in and slaughter innocent people
in most cases this is they are not
really bigoted the Charleston Church
shooting is a different case ok that
clearly was bigotry but most of the time
I think it's not bigotry it's not even
really hatred
even if the person is shooting up a
school and he has some grudge against
the people in the school but I think
that's not really what's driving it
and because what what do you hear from
the survivors of these shootings the
ones who witness this happen and they
see the guy in the act what do they
always say you almost never hear about a
guy walking into a building screaming
obscenities and just there's you know
he's his face is red and he's on fire
with rage and he spraying bullets at
these people that he hates that's kind
of the scene you would expect to see
right
but know what you always hear is that
they walk into a building and they have
a blank expression on their face
and they are practically yawning while
they go around killing innocent people
they do it casually and if you could
zoom in and just see their face and see
nothing and see you hear nothing else
you would almost think well that's the
face of a man waiting in line at the
post office or at the DMV you know
that's what you would think because it's
just or that's just the face of a guy
sitting in traffic it's this bored
despondent empty face
so again that goes to this emptiness and
this indifference
ever everyday on the news you see
another example of this kind of thing
some of the most extreme examples stand
out we remember them you may remember
the case a couple years ago of the the
people who kidnapped the disabled man
and tortured him and
broadcast it live on Facebook I don't
know if you remember that case but right
after it happened there were people
saying oh this is a hate crime it's
hateful
no because they were laughing while they
did it they didn't hate this guy wasn't
hate they didn't have anything against
him personally
they were just utterly indifferent to
his life
so they thought they would amuse
themselves by torturing him that's all
they didn't hate him
what they felt towards him was something
even lower than hatred
another case of teenagers who laughed
and made fun of a guy while he drowned
in a reservoir
there was a very troubled man who went
out and drowned that I guess he trying
to drown himself in a lake or a
reservoir and there were teenagers that
happen to be standing on the shore and
on the bank and and they saw it happen
they made no attempt to call 9-1-1 they
made no attempt to save him and instead
they just laughed and they made fun
again they didn't hate the guy they
didn't know him
they were just completely indifferent to
his life think again of all the cases of
unfortunately there are so many cases of
people committing suicide and and
livestreaming it and what do you hear
about every time one of this these
things happen you'll always hear about
the people that watch the live stream
and they cheer and they encourage the
person to kill themselves do they hate
that person no they don't hate the
person they don't know them if nothing
against them they just feel nothing
towards them
less extreme but still and other
examples is most of the vitriol and the
vile putrid filth that you see people
spewing at each other online you look at
the comments in the other YouTube video
or on Twitter or whatever and people say
the most vile awful things to each other
and about other people but there's not
really hatred in it it's just complete
emptiness look I get I get a lot of I
mean take it from me I get so much of
this myself
and I would even I'll even you know for
lack of a better term I'll call it hate
mail and I get so much of it
and anyone right now you could look at
the comment I mean I no matter what I
say or do online the comments section we
filled with people who are just ripping
me to shreds right
but on the rare occasion when I make the
mistake of reading some of that stuff
what I find is it's not it's like they
don't even really seem angry they're
just these are just empty sad people
who are just
reacting this way
they're reacting this way because they
find some amusement amuses them it's
entertainment
and also for me personally the kind of
things I talk about what I'm trying to
get to you know if I'm if I'm trying to
break people out of that apathy and out
of that out of that indifference well
they're gonna react strongly against
that
because for them they cling closely to
it and to and to be you know when you
try to separate them from it they start
to feel vulnerable and scared and afraid
apathy and this indifference is also
kind of a defense mechanism
so all of that it's just indifferent
the rising suicide rate itself it speaks
to this indifference the drug abuse
epidemic are our supposed mental health
crisis throw in all of our subsea
watching and our addiction to
smartphones and the internet and the
rabid kind of materialism that you see
in our culture the collapse of the
family the decline in religion all of
this goes back to the same thing
emptiness indifference apathy so here's
the secret about the nature of the
disputes in our country most of the
combatants screaming and fighting at
each other you know it and and and and
throwing insults back and forth most of
them don't actually care
that much
are saying talking points there were
there you know saying what they think
they're supposed to say they're
repeating their lines
that they've been given
people on the other side are giving
their lines but it's all just theater
most of these people they don't care
they haven't even thought about these
issues
they've given no thought to them
whatsoever I shared this story couple
days ago I was just just one example of
so many that you see online but I was
scrolling through Facebook she days ago
and I saw on my newsfeed someone had
posted something about Trump's Jerusalem
policy and so in the comments section
there were five five or six people going
back and forth fighting over this and it
was a very contentious angry fight and
they were insulting each other but just
reading through it I got I got that I
got the I got the distinction distinct
impression reading through this exchange
of previous people I got the distinct
impression that number one nobody
involved in this discussion knows what
they're talking about it really appears
that none of them had even thought about
this issue prior to that morning prior
to it being in the news they had not
even thought about it they give it no
thought whatsoever and but now suddenly
they're pretending to not only know
about it but to feel passionately all of
a sudden they've their pastor on fire
with passion about it but it's I find
their passion really unconvincing
so you get the impression number one
that they don't know anything about it
and number two that they don't really
care
they're having this fight and it's just
something to do and then they'll quickly
go on to the other thing you can even
imagine I mean in your head you could
imagine like one of these guys in line
at Starbucks typing furiously no you're
so stupid you're wrong oh yeah yeah I'll
have a venti mocha with extra whip yeah
please
you're so stupid I can't believe yeah I
mean it's just it's nothing it's just
something it's just something for him to
do while he's doing other things
and that's how most of our discussions
go we're not really a hateful people I
think we are callous but we're not
hateful
I think it's indifference that informs
every aspect of American
and hollow in different callous people
they don't fight civil wars
they just kind of float softly into
oblivion
think that's going to be our fate if we
don't stay in our current trajectory if
we if we do stay on our current
trajectory
the country is not going to break apart
we're going to remain stuck together
but our unity is not any kind of it's
not dude any kind of common
understanding or shared understanding
it's just sort of this paralysis
you
or maybe it's more accurate to say that
we're together because what else are we
supposed to do
indifference is far worse than hatred
far worse
we worry so much about hatred hatred
really isn't a hatred isn't such a
terrible thing I mean it's not good but
you can work with hatred when somebody
is hateful you know like if somebody
really hates you really hates you
well it's not good it's not you know you
prefer if they didn't
but that means that they there there's
something they feel something towards
you they care about you they care about
you in a negative way but they do care
about you so there's a real feeling
there there's a there's a caring there's
a there's a passion directed at you
and so it's not that difficult you know
you've got the raw material to work with
hatred is just love turned upside down
so all you got to do is just turn it
right-side up
it's not that hard to turn a hateful
person into a loving person
because you've already got that fire and
that passion there
all you got to do is just you've just
got to make things right
got to put them in their proper place
and context
difference is nothing there's no raw
material there's nothing to work
in differences
just a blank a blank space
and if somebody's indifferent to you
well then
that's the worst thing because there's
nothing there to work
and I think that's what we struggle with
in our society
you
I certainly don't know how to solve that
I mean we can't on our own you can't
take an indifferent person and make them
not that any more
so we have to rely on prayer and rely on
God but in the meantime I really think
that
if there is any antidote aside from
prayer to indifference it is real
passion and conviction
and so I try to bring that to a
discussions because as I said I think
that's the only way to break through
that if there's any way to break through
that indifference and get to the core of
a person
and make some care I think that's the
way to do it
all right thank you for caring enough to
watch this whole ramble and I will have
a great weekend I'll talk to y'all
mother Godspeed